I remember once working with a woman
who found it really frustrating
that someone in her office
loudly ate rice around
lunchtime every day
and her metal fork would constantly
be hitting against the bowl
and she was so annoyed by it
that she was actually going to go out
and buy a wooden fork
for this person.
When you think we spend
half our waking life at work
if there's someone who
really gets under your skin,
it's crucial to cross that divide.
We've probably all worked
with people we don't like
but really?
You hate them,
you actually hate them?
That takes an enormous
amount of energy
and it makes little
or no difference to them.
If they've really done something
totally illegal or horrendous
there's probably
much better remedies for it.
Most of the time we find
that people want to avoid having
a conversation with the other person
because they dislike them,
but if you don’t talk about it
it won't get better by itself.
So some people try to put it off
and develop coping mechanisms
but it rarely makes
the situation much better
and soon it's years down the line
and you're still in the same boat,
hating this person.
It doesn't have to be like this.
A bit of short term pain,
i.e. a difficult but open
and honest conversation
with the person you dislike,
can bring a long-term gain.
We get people telling us
we're intimidating
when we think we're really cuddly
or telling us that we're shy
when we consider ourselves
thoughtful and serious.
So think about what you
give off to other people.
Here's Ali. He's very bright.
He's quite young,
he's very highly educated.
He's just got a great job
so he's sent to a conference
and because, as well as being bright,
he's rather modest
he decides that he'll keep quiet,
pretty much,
and he'll just observe
what's going on
and listen to people
who are more experienced.
The people around him
who have heard how bright he is
and how well-educated
see him being a bit restrained
and a bit withheld
and start to think,
"He's a bit aloof."
"He doesn't rate us."
"He thinks he's too good for us."
And so they start to freeze him out.
We end up with a situation where
everybody's misunderstanding
each other and nobody
is getting the benefit of their
different abilities and experiences.
Ask questions and seek to understand
the other person's viewpoint.
Then show them
you've understood their viewpoint
by summarising back to them
what they have said -
an incredibly powerful little tool
for building rapport.
Too often, people just try to
persuade others of their case
but if you show that you're open
to listening to the other person
and genuinely want to understand
where they're coming from,
you'll have a much more
constructive conversation.
I remember once in a mediation
where one person shouted at the other
"You're a..."
Now I don’t have a problem
with someone saying that
if that's how they feel
but I do actually
with how it's worded.
If you tell someone they're a liar,
they'll automatically disagree.
We all would.
But if you calmly point out
that on this occasion and
this occasion they have lied to you
you can have a conversation about it
without them getting as defensive.
It's probably not personal.
Remember that you don't have to
learn to like the person
that you're in conflict with -
you just have to work with them.
Be willing to challenge your
assumptions and then learn from that.
Welcome other's ideas and approaches.
Be yourself, be open, be honest about
your own strengths and contributions.
The really great thing is
if you're doing those things,
not only does it diminish
that feeling of dislike
and make you better
at working with people,
but you might actually get
to enjoy working with them.
If you liked that, subscribe to the BBC Ideas YouTube channel.
Lots more top tips on how to be successful at work.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)